[Music]
when you get into the astronaut corps
there are two things that you have to
demonstrate to fly on a either a shuttle
or a a Space Station mission and they
are the ability to go into this you know
this 300 pound suit and do something
called space walking and the way that
you train for that is you get in this
white suit that's pressurized and you go
down you know 25 feet and a 5 million
gallon pool to simulate you are building
and creating the space station under
underneath the the pool deck there was a
submerged space station a summer space
shuttle so that's how you demonstrate
that and and when I have my chance to
train in that environment I had an
accident where I lost all my hearing and
I they operated on my ear they wouldn't
looked around they couldn't find
anything they told me I would never fly
in space so for a while there after my
hearing did slowly come back in my right
ear I'm deaf in this year they told me
that you know we're gonna have to figure
out what to do with you and that was a
that was a really tough time for me
because I you know I never thought of
myself becoming an astronaut but once I
got into the astronaut program then you
know I was you know solitarily focused
on you know trying to do this thing and
they sent me to Washington DC to work in
education we were we were choosing
teachers to become astronauts and one of
those astronauts was Ricky Arnold who
just came home about two months ago
doing education in space doing
spacewalks doing all these things
and while I was kicking this program off
and helping run this program I was
driving from DC to my hometown Lynchburg
Virginia and I get a phone call from my
boss at the time who's new to NASA she
says Leland what does it mean when the
Space Shuttle countdown clock is now
counting up and I said how much is the
counting up she says there's 10 seconds
in 15 seconds and this was space shuttle
Columbia
and that moment I knew that all my
friends were dead and so I turned around
and drove back to DC to headquarters and
they sent me to David Brown's parents
home in Washington Virginia
to console his family who just lost
their son of this most tragic horrific
way and I'm and I'm going to the house
and I get to the door and I hug his
mother Dottie and I walk over to his
father his father says to me with tears
in his eyes he says Leland my son is
gone there is nothing you can do to
bring him back but the biggest tragedy
would be if we don't continue to fly in
space to honor their legacy and I'm
trying to figure out how I will honor
their legacy if I'm not gonna find space
because I'm medically disqualified
long story short as we go to the
memorial services the chief of all the
flight surgeons watches to me clear my
ears as we take off and land in the NASA
airplane and he signs me a waiver to fly
in space and I go back to Houston and I
get assigned to a flight even though I
don't have any hearing in my left ear
and so that was a trying to stay focused
on the task of you know helping others
get ready for mission still doing my job
at NASA whether it's an education or
robotics or whatever I was doing and I
and I had friends telling me you should
quit nasty you should sue them write the
tell-all book and get paid and I wasn't
raised like that my my parents always
taught me to try to do the right thing
you know no matter what happens to you
you know stay focused and and try to try
to do the right things that was one of
the hardest things that had happened to
state is to stay focused on the mission
when I'm you know internalizing all of
my own you know am I gonna fly and I'm
never gonna hear in this year you know
that the the chords and the overtones
don't sound the same when the piano as
they used to because I had perfect
hearing and and then when I got that
piece of paper that says you are now
free to fly and getting that first
mission 3 2 1 liftoff thinking of
honoring the legacy of my friends that
had passed because that's what his
father told me to do the night of the
accident and I did that and it was
perfect and we install things and we we
built the Space Station and it was just
an amazing transformation from being at
one of the lowest points in my life in
the hospital bed not
I couldn't hear a bomb drop - now flying
in space in building something
incredible
[Music]